[Music]
Chuck some time ago we did an explainer
on being speciesist I don't know if you
remember that I exist if you're you know
you can be sexist racist you can be
speciesist right and I don't remember
everything I talked about but one
example would be you know we all or many
people uh
ecologically conscious people will buy
line caught tuna mine cartoon and you
know why of course yeah because the net
caught tuna uh does a great deal of harm
to uh the cutest animal
that swims and breathes air yeah none
other than our reigning champion of the
dolphin yeah flipper flipper the dolphin
yes yeah so it's air breathing so gets
trapped in the net and it can't breathe
and it dies and so you buy line caught
tuna you don't kill the Dolphins and but
of course when you buy length line
called tuna you're killing the tuna so
so this is this is a speciesist decision
you're making all right preferring to
kill one kind of animal instead of
another for whatever your reasons may be
right okay okay so uh let me just say
you like this theme I know
because uh you have a new book coming
out which you were kind enough to send
me in advance and uh sent you an
advanced copy did I do that okay you
sent me the transcript it was great oh
yeah oh early oh yeah it was way back
yeah before it was uh yeah
yeah uh yeah you got a chapter on there
uh that basically discusses this which
is yeah a lot of that early thinking
went into this chapter and so I want to
add a little you didn't even plug your
book
what what is wrong with you I just
mentioned that you got a new book coming
out you're like oh yes of course yeah a
lot of thinking no bro I'm setting you
up I'm like okay it's called Starry
Messenger by the way people Cosmic
perspectives on civilization yes and it
takes whole sectors of our lives and
shows you what they look like if you're
scientifically literate yeah and have a
cosmic perspective on it because truth
and Beauty uh life and death right more
indeed mind and body word peace which I
changed by the way because it was mostly
people in Conflict but not necessarily
killing each other although I do a lot
of discussion about warranty so I
changed the title that since you saw it
and it's now conflict and resolution
which is a broader sense of how people
uh deal with is exploration and
Discovery uh gender and identity yes I
did get that you remember that gender
and identity another one color and race
yeah I went there yeah there and another
one meterians and vegetables and
vegetarians yes so that's one of my
favorite because because I was reading
that and I was like this this dude
trying to get canceled
canceled
a lot of vegetarians because you know
how you know first of all they're very
very moody because they're hungry
they're hungry let's be honest very
moody people
and by the way veggie people these are
all jokes okay they're jokes I'm very
happy I'm very happy for you to live
that lifestyle and quite frankly you're
uh taking a great burden off of not only
the ecology but uh climate mitigation so
yeah okay there you go are you happy in
fact is it okay
not back to the jokes back to the jokes
so the meterians and vegetarians chapter
the book is not people will think it's
Rife with opinions but it's not the book
is just what the world looks like when
you're scientifically literate and you
know how to think about data and
information and Analysis and and also
what it looks like from above from the
cosmic perspective and I occasionally
throw in some aliens right aliens who
have no preconceived notion of who and
what we are and they just observe yeah
they just observe as they call it the um
the dispassionate third-party Observer
Observer correct and so in one example I
just imagine suppose
um let me work my way there for a moment
okay so this this landed in the book uh
let's say you don't like killing animals
right maybe that's why you're vegetarian
okay right nothing wrong with that is a
point of philosophy and many such people
who live in homes might have mouse traps
in their basement that are Humane you've
heard of Humane mouse traps it doesn't
snap the neck Catch and Release trap
cats Catch and Release and you got to
get down there quickly because they
don't they dry up pretty fast
um in the in the Trap if you if you're
not there checking on it every few days
so you trap money so there's the cute
fuzzy little fellow mammal and then you
release it into the wild and you feel
good right all right but if you Analyze
This you realize that the life
expectancy of the mouse in the wild is
between 9 and 18 months because they are
the tastiest of snacks for all manner of
Woodland Predators delicious owls and
Hawks and crows and foxes and so what
you've done is shortened the life of the
mouse by offering them up to Predators
whereas if you let it alone in your
basement it would live up to six years
so if you really cared about the life of
that Mouse you would welcome it into
your basement and have it bring all his
friends while it's happening right so so
this notion that you're against killing
animals maybe you're okay with them
Dying by other means but it's not a
fully thought through Philosophy by just
saving the life of the mouse instead of
snapping its neck because you'd rather
see getting swallowed whole by an owl
because the deal is it's not really
about the mouse it's about you oh oh and
how you feel it's how you feel it's why
okay you saved Mouse after that you
don't give it you don't give a rat's ass
to what happened to the mouse
good luck Mickey
so
so I thought when I was writing the book
every chapter I tried to offer what it
what we look like we what we might look
like to aliens right okay so imagine
aliens that are that uh photosynthesize
like plants right okay so they're
actually
plant-based sentient life instead of
meat based sentient life okay so so they
they thrive on Sun lamps that are in
their ship or on their host star all
right so nobody ever kills anything they
just sort of they just lay out of the
Sun and you absorb the light
there it is oh I got it today sunlight
is delicious guys
I don't know what's happening with all
this UV but it's amazing
my compliments to the chef all right it
needs a little more salt though exactly
so so if they come to earth like what
would they observe so the funny part is
they would see the meat eaters and
wouldn't really fully understand them
right all right they're these meat-based
creatures killing other meat-based
creatures
for their survival but they won't really
care because they're only they're only
going to care about their own Brethren
which are the the plants because they've
heard that there's a great biodiversity
of plant life on Earth which is this is
in there this is on their in their tour
guide right so they come through they
see the rainforests and they see the
jungles and they see all and they see
the the sequoia trees in in the Pacific
Northwest and they're just Delight in
this
and then
they find a subset of humans
who specifically Target plants
to slaughter
and this this this would kind of freak
them out because these are their felt
these are their Brethren and so here
they are cultivating plants to harvest
them and eat them and by the way you'll
feel sorry for our plants because our
plants can't run away because they're
scenting and they can like walk around
sentient ways that we and ambulatory
right in ambulatory that's the word I'm
going to thank you they can get around
whereas our plants can't so they watch
humans a particular subset of humans
walk up to a plant and decapitate it
okay right to be consumed okay well fine
the what they can't but it's it goes
deeper all right what they observe is
that this subset of humans we call them
vegetarians specifically Target the
reproductive organs of the plants right
the seeds the the nuts the berries the
flowers the all the things the plant is
just trying to make another version of
itself and we reach in there snatch it
and eat it
this would look particularly barbaric to
them
but wait there's more then they they go
by the produce aisle at Whole Foods and
or any large grocery store would have
this and then they see what people are
especially buying right they're about if
there's a there's a bit of infanticide
going on exactly why because the people
are seeking out baby spinach the baby
versions of everything and the bean
sprouts
so so that they were just completely
freak and they they run away and leave
Earth as fast as they can or they bring
their armies to defend the plants or
they'd end up in a salad because
hopefully they didn't hopefully they
didn't land next to these vegetarians
because
so it's just another way to look at what
you're doing as a vegetarian it's a life
form that occupies a sector of the tree
of life and you have decided that
because we are if it's for animal safety
and pain and all this rather than
through uh through the environment okay
because of course meat eaters are much
more costly to the environment than
plant eaters all right
um and I of course I go there in the
book and describe these differences and
how and why and but the consequences are
um I'm just saying that you
um
if the cosmic perspective makes you look
at things fresh
because someone coming in seeing our
tree of life doesn't have a species bias
coming in at all right and they're going
to wonder so here you are saving the
mouse into your basement okay but what's
your house made of well it's made of the
wood from 50 trees that might have lived
100 years but they were cut down
halfway through their lives each tree
produces 15 times the mass of the mouse
in oxygen every day
but no you cut them down to make your
floorboards your wall panels your two by
fours your structural members your wall
sightings
so what you've done with trees and by
the way trees like I said they can live
50 100 years some live a thousand years
they're home for all manner of forest
creatures the birds squirrels
um uh insects and even other even other
Flora other other Flora correct growing
in and around and on them and so we can
ask the question
who do you think nature cares more about
right the tree that's that might live A
Thousand Years or 100 years or the one
ounce
Mouse
that you just saved I'm getting it's in
that it's next net
so uh now I don't
care what you think after all this I
mean I do I care in the sense that I'm
an educator and I want you to be fully
informed but if you're going to run
around yeah you get a run around
choosing one species over another look
at the big picture first and then go
pick and choose what you want to eat and
what you don't want to eat and what you
want to kill and what you don't want to
kill you know I'm I get it a lot of it
has to do with Consciousness and a lot
of it has to do with
um how people feel a philosophy how they
feel philosophy the people who say the
people who say we value our life because
we have a beating heart and then the
trees don't and then I'll say maybe it's
not that the tree is missing a beating
heart maybe the tree simply doesn't need
because the tree does have a circulatory
system
if you cut a tree does it not bleed yeah
does it not suffocate if you cut off its
nutrients does it not with
that's right so so to turn around and
say the the mouse I care about but cut
down the tree because I have there's a
home I want to build just rebalance that
and come back to the conversation and
you'd be surprised how differently you
might be thinking right don't be like me
and just eat mice they're delicious
you fight for the mice with the with the
owl my juicy mouth exactly
it's all right Chuck that's that's
another explainer there I like it what
what the vegetarian world might look
like to photosynthesizing aliens yeah
nice yeah I love it I love it all right
so this has been yet another explainer
of Star Talk thanks Chuck for always
being there always a pleasure feel the
grass places keep looking up
foreign
[Music]